i was i was uh going through my bag my
like
do you have like [ __ ] papers in your
bag that just crushed down that you're
like the [ __ ] is in this [ __ ] yeah then
you finally like claw it out and you're
like god that's disgusting but
i pulled one out and it was like an
anime expo pamphlet from when i went to
anime
really and i was like
i miss annabel exposed so much i i i
miss anime conventions
so much i miss large crowds i miss
getting sick from all the people [ __ ]
yes i never thought i'd miss confluence
god i just want to be sneezed on him
don't worry about dying yeah
i just want to handshake with like the
sweatiest weebs
i want a hug that's a little too damp
for my liking just like you know
what i want i want to put a ham on my
shoulder and the shoulders like really
wet for some reason
i miss going into the gaming room and
just feeling like the dampness of the
atmosphere
yeah like the [ __ ] i don't know what
it is about the gaming room and
everything because
everyone said it's all the men from all
the players accumulating
it's all the game of thrones like the
[ __ ] room needs its own weather
report you know you know what i mean
like like a humidity mushroom cloudy so
there's always mushrooms growing in that
room 92
humidity yeah but uh let's talk about
the actual topic
of this episode which is uh funny or
weird conventional just conventions
period just because like we've i've been
seriously craving
conventions honestly i never thought
like i i i think i think i hit a new low
the other day
guys because because being stuck in the
country you know
i'm very used to you know flying out and
going to conventions and stuff
so like casey neistat video started
getting recommended to me of like him
sitting in like first-class seats
yeah and then and then i watch one and
then i watch the entire series because i
just missed
the feeling of being in an airplane so
i'm just like
god i wish that was me right now because
it's like it is chair reclining
oh god it's so uncomfortable i miss it i
miss it so much
every time sydney comes in to be like a
beef please
it's like this is fun yeah i remember i
think it was a
i don't remember what was last episode
or the episode before but you were
talking about like
this is the longest period i've ever
been like that i've spent not being on a
plane yeah and so many comments in the
subreddit and being like wow that was
the most privileged thing
yeah that's true but it's true like no
because you know even you know i didn't
come from a very privileged background
but
it's just it's just part of coming from
an international background i would say
because
i mean i'm you know i'm i'm full like my
full blood is thai but i was raised in
england
so any chance we could get to fly back
home to thailand
right we did and that was just that was
just part of my life you know every year
i'd go
back and visit grandma yeah and visit my
friends from
america america as well as well yeah
damn good good privilege deflect god
i'm not privileged i'm blessed
yeah but like i don't know like just it
made me miss
like this year was just the lack of
conventions because i thought at least
that like
maybe there might be like some smaller
conventions that we could go to here
because in my in the back of my head
like just the other day i was the same
though in japan like i missed the kind
of scummy action oh no no of course but
i mean like
yeah i get that but i mean i've been to
a few conventions in japan it's still
pretty [ __ ] fun
because like just the other day in the
back of my head i was like well i'm
probably stuck in japan
until what at least like end of april i
think the japanese government said
so in my head i was like oh that means i
can go to winter comic ad finally
but then but then i was like wait
conventions aren't going
[ __ ] the one time i can go to winter
comic
and winter comic is not happening
exactly that [ __ ] sucks
all the stories i heard about comiket is
just basically it's you go in and you
buy
the merchandise or buy the dojinshi or
whatever and then you leave you know
that's what i heard yeah i mean it's not
like the convention experience that we
have
think of america think of anime expo or
any convention but the entire convention
is the artist ally right that's what
comic head is
it's just a stupid amount of just
tables and desks where dojon artists are
selling their doujins honestly though
honestly i remember when you know when
you first go when you first go to
conventions right
i remember like the first conventions
you go to i try to go to every panel
yeah i'd have a [ __ ] full-on schedule
where i'm really like okay
this is the time to go to the panel this
is the time i'm gonna hit like the
artist ally this is gonna be the time we
hit up like the convention floor and
everything yeah and now
you you go you go to enough conventions
and you're just like whatever right
i i i think you gonna document he's just
like let's go to chick-fil-a
i've i've never been to a panel that
isn't my friends or my own
yeah i mean i've never been to i've
never like just seen a panel like that
looks fun i'll go like i just don't like
i'd rather eat yeah
eating eating is great but i'm not going
to hang out with people now now my
favorite place to go in the actual
convention is probably the artist danny
because the artist ali
when i first started going was the place
that i never hit up and then
now you go to enough conventions and you
live in japan as well
and you go to like the the main hall and
most of the stuff you can
you can find in the main hall is like
synonymous across all right
but i feel like artist ali is where you
find all the actual cool [ __ ]
that's the thing right it's like the
only usually with conventions the only
thing about a convention a lot of the
times that's completely different to any
other convention is the artist
yeah because you'll always find some
[ __ ] artist or whatever where he's
like oh [ __ ] i've never seen that before
because you go down like to the regular
thing and as you said it's like oh i
could just
[ __ ] buy this in ocarina for like a
third of the price yeah exactly what's
the point
and the thing is especially being on
trash days i've realized how limited my
wardrobe is oh yeah like like cycling
through all the t-shirts i have because
most of the time every time i go to an
anime convention i buy like two or three
t-shirts from the artist alley
so just just because i haven't gone to
the any conventions this year
i haven't i'm out i haven't been able to
recycle any of my new clothes or
anything like that
yeah i saw a comment that was like oh my
god connor's wearing the same shirt that
he wore in episode like two and it's
like episode 19 i'm like
how many [ __ ] shirts do you own do
you expect to throw them away when i'm
done
i i still haven't worn the same shirt
yet because now that it's getting colder
i can finally bust out my long sleeves
i'm like thank god i was about to run
out of
my short sleeve t-shirts i wore a one
shirt like a lot recently and
i got a [ __ ] comment that was like
why you was wearing that shirt i'm like
you never heard of a [ __ ] laundry
machine like washing machine like what
the [ __ ] what do you mean like why am i
always wearing the same shirt
like what do you wear a shirt once when
you throw it away wash your shirts i'm
confused why is this weird i don't
understand
yeah but but i mean like that's all they
say a weak span on trash tastes
might as well just be a day to them yes
made me self-conscious about how just
how many clothes i have in my wardrobe
yeah and how many shirts i can get away
with with without recycling
the same thing too many times that
people can notice yeah i mean especially
with you because you
very rarely like actually make a
physical appearance in your videos right
yeah exactly normally you don't have to
normally i don't care about this [ __ ]
normally i'm just a [ __ ] disembodied
voice i mean who knows like god might be
butt naked when he's [ __ ] filming the
audio for you never know